[Musique]
à Paris la nuit pigale s'illumine
Sur le seuil des bar des lèvres vous
invité
sous-les
lampes crues des sourires
fardent dans un Coin perdu deux amoureux
IL
[Musique]
concernant porte mooi bien loin bien loin
d'ici mooi la-bas dans ton
paie
arrache mooi de ce monde o Je
vis
import Moi bien loin bien loin
d'ici Paris la nuit et le cur
vieillissent
Vite sous les lampes crues des sourires
toi
invite-les sous eux
lampes crues souvenirs
grimac dans un Coin
perdu nos deux am sans
fille
emporte-moi bien loin bien loin
d'ici
emporte-moi la-bas dans ton
paie
arrache mooi de ce monde ou je vis
[Musique]
emporte-moi bien loin bien loin
d'ici Au petit
matin le ciel devient tout
Rose le Cartier se c'est l'heure où l'on
Arrose Au dernier bist que le patron
fait la
gueule une fem
mon bar chante tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sors, comporte-toi bien Moi, eh bien,
[Musique]
d'ici